welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm really excited
to be joined by nathan darnell
who is the founder of source control who
are an
expert tech recruitment business
specializing in distributed systems
and this business he launched in january
this year
before that nathan successfully climbed
the ranks to
associate director and along the way won
multiple awards like top biller and
consultant
of the year awards back to back in 2018
and 2019
at his previous company um that he
worked for oakwell hampton
and now nathan has big goals big plans
to grow his own
recruitment business with source control
nathan thanks for coming on the podcast
thank you very much for having me a
lovely introduction
yes i'm excited to to go over this with
you so
obviously we're going to talk about
recent times you being a business owner
but we're gonna have a real good
conversation on you being a biller
getting that top biller award and these
types of things but the first question
i want to ask you and where we start is
in your opinion what what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
yeah i mean i thought quite a lot about
this question and
it's hard to kind of stay away i suppose
from the cliches that you'd normally
hear
in terms of kind of determination
resilience goal orientated self-belief
but
i think to be successful it comes down
to well one of the main factors
it is kind of a large dose of
individuality um
i think every everyone can bring various
different kind of strengths to the table
and it's knowing how to leverage those
strengths to kind of your advantage
i mean some people i've seen in the past
be you know fantastic
write in the perfect ed email um and we
quit the phones but i think it's
it's kind of a combination of playing to
your strengths but doing the other stuff
anyway
you know it's like it's spinning those
plates and
and being kind of you know um having the
awareness to know that
brilliant you look this is my main
tactic for example but
you know i'm also gonna do the other
things that i need to do to make sure
i'm being successful which could be the
you know the cold call and the bd and
stuff like that um
yeah so that that would be the kind of
my key takeaway um obviously those are
the buzzwords i mentioned
equally as important the resilient side
because you know there's
massive good days and awful bad days
determination kind of setting the goals
knowing what you want to achieve and
going out there to try and achieve those
goals
um and yeah just belief in yourself that
you know
that you know you can do it the glass
ceiling is is what you make it i suppose
and
and you know it's most certainly easy to
smash through it if you've got the right
um you know the right kind of set of
police behind you
i love that individuality is that
obviously i think another word that a
lot of people use is authentic
right and i know you it's like you spoke
about in an interesting way but i guess
how do you think people can uncover
their individuality because i think
that's interesting i i think it's
again there's probably no right or wrong
answer for that it really comes down to
yourself
and what what you're good and stronger
and it's you know morally kind of
you know you have to do it um you know
by trial and error sometimes
you just gotta you know there's in any
business when you when you know when you
when you're joining a business when
you're starting off in recruitment
whether you've got a couple of years
experience or a lot of years experience
you know
it's still always a learning curve um
and it's always about kind of
for me variating things and just trying
trying things in different ways in new
ways and learning what works for you
because
what works for you isn't necessarily
going to work for the person sitting
next to you and vice versa
but it's always good to kind of leverage
the advice and of your peers and be able
to try and put that into practice
and just work out for yourself you know
is is that what i'm good at when i'm
stronger
um or is that somewhere essentially i
need to do to develop
and you know most importantly as well
alongside that it's being coachable
it's leaning probably on the advice of
your peers because you know they'll be
able to identify and potentially spot
you know strengths and weaknesses within
you um that you know you can potentially
improve on
yeah i love that and i guess what you're
also talking about there is
self-awareness right yeah
like would you if you think sort of
nathan
early on in his career and i love that
you also mentioned
around always being open to learn like i
think anyone listening to this
definitely has that mindset and i think
it's the mindset that most top builders
will share and besides the ones that
obviously have a huge ego and think
they've completed recruitment
but i definitely think there's a lot
less of those people in my opinion but
i don't know i'm just curious as we're
here and then we'll go into other things
but like do you
how do you feel like have you always
been someone that's been self-aware how
have you
cultivated yourself awareness absolutely
absolutely absolutely not
um you know it was i've had to have to
learn through mistakes
and um you know for me personally um
yeah i kind of
i understood my purpose what i wanted to
do what i wanted to achieve and
you know i'd always set myself those
goals that i wanted to progress to that
next level to go from from
consultant to senior consultant through
and upwards um and you know
at certain points throughout my career
in all honesty you know i had to have
difficult conversations with
with them the powers that be in the
directors above me in regards
to you know even simple things about
doing the basics
attitude um just just those general
things you know around that and some you
know sometimes
i've had to i've had to adapt change
learn and grow from that
um to be able to achieve you know what
i've wanted to achieve personally
because
you know without those changes um you
know i probably probably wouldn't have
been given the opportunities that i have
done so far
i'm not telling people to change
themselves fundamentally because as i
say that comes
plays back into the individuality um but
it's more about how
to how do you learn and adapt and take
on that feedback and grow from that
feedback to
you know make yourself a better rounded
um individual not just as a recruiter
but you know somebody that's in the
office as well because
as you move up in the ranks you know so
so do people lean to you for more advice
and and and look as you as a bit more of
a role model within a business
so it's really important as i say that
you know you take take that on board
and kind of run with it yeah thank you
for sharing that so
2014 then you entered the uh
recruitment world similar background it
looks like you was
a life insurance broker i was a
personal lions insurance broker sending
people uh
car insurance and all that good stuff so
tell us about obviously that the world
that i came from i don't know what it
was like for you maybe a bit different
than life insurance but like
it was super transactional like the
world that i was coming in i wanted to
expand my sales skills and and get
getting more of a consultant position
and
deal with bigger deal values and things
like that but describe to us your
your first year in recruitment what what
was that like how did you just yeah
it was a bit of a baptism of fire um in
fairness
a big learning curve as you've kind of
mentioned there um
in insurance sales and such and many
many sales jobs it's very transactional
it's very
kind of process driven so you know you
follow it to your process
and hopefully at the end of that process
you get someone's bank details and
you're happy
when you're you know when coming into
recruitment there was just so much so
much more
um to take into consideration because
you know you're no longer selling a
product that ever works or it doesn't
you know you're dealing with people and
you know they're one of the most
volatile commodities out there because
everyone's got their own opinions
they've got
you know their own their own kind of key
indicators that they need to tick off
and stuff like that so
it was more for me kind of a big
adjustment in learning the psychology
around around kind of around recruitment
first and foremost but also
you know trying to get a better
understand people and people's needs and
you know as i say it's until you until
you know what somebody needs
it's really hard to sell against that
yeah and
what was the environment that you went
into was it a small business or
yeah yeah there was small small to
medium kind of business
um i reckon there's probably about 30 of
us at the peak it was quite it was it
was
probably um a bit of a diverse kind of
recruitment culture so we had a couple
of different revenue streams so it
wasn't just technology orientated so
i was part of the technology team but we
also had white collar and blue collar
engineering
and apprenticeship programs as well but
he was still one big team or be
obviously working in different kind of
revenue streams
so i guess looking back i guess
just two things i just want to know from
you what was your
sort of biggest challenge in in the sort
of it doesn't have to be specifically
the first year but
early on in that first conference you
worked for um
and then i'm i want to know sort of what
your best sort of piece of advice would
be for anyone listening to this that's
early on in their recruitment career so
let's go to the challenges first like i
guess
what so you mentioned a bit about there
what you had to adapt to the psychology
and things like that but
any other challenges and obstacles that
you had to work through
earlier it was just for me probably
coming into it was it was a bit of a
stark difference in terms of the level
of professionalism um that was required
you know i'd been in in sales
environments where you know things got
pretty wild at times and
uh you know um it was it was kind of
high-risk reward type environments and
such like that but
um coming into into recruitment for for
me the big culture shock and the big
challenge was
was kind of changing a certain kind of
areas of myself and
my sales process and my behaviors and
such to to kind of
modify and fit into this recruitment
environment
and how i mean i i i really had to do
the same and i um
i went into i just really got into like
my sales
basically like how did obviously i'm
assuming that
you sort of spoke to people around you
and your peers but like how did you go
about
upskilling yourself besides learning on
the job i've been trying
it was again i was lucky to have
some close friends that were in
recruitment actually gave me kind of
the the nudge and and the the insight
and basically i wanted one of my one of
my best friends called me up and
he was living down in bristol at the
time um working for opus recruitment
and uh you know he got probably the
dream yeah he did
he did he just called me up and he was
pretty pretty easy to tell me the dream
he just said you know this is this is
the job that you probably meant to do
mate so uh definitely you know
definitely really
yeah uh and then then the next week i
had five interviews and
uh yeah i just kind of committed to that
so um for me it was
probably a pivotal change from where i
was looking from you know just
the general sales jobs that i've been a
part of previously and now looking to
where can i make a career where can i
grow something long-term
and really really expand on that because
i mean i was only 23
24 coming into recruitment um that's
late by some people's standards
um you know when you when you've got
graduates and such like that
so you know i knew that that that next
move for me was something that i was
going to stick to and something i was
going to dedicate myself to because
you know the last thing i wanted to be
doing is you know a couple of years in
and being back on the drawing board and
thinking okay that didn't work out for
me what's next
that's nice yeah so i guess to to round
that off then like anyone listening
like if you could go back and speak to
nathan early on like what what advice
would you give him do you think yeah i
would probably just tell him to
um believe in the trust in the process
and follow the process
um you know it's it's really easy to to
hear things sometimes but not listen
um and kind of make assumptions and hear
probably what you want to hear and
uh or maybe kind of you know glaze over
the things you don't want to hear
because simply
you know it adds that's a little bit
concerning to something but
um just just to be really thorough um
you know
throughout the whole throughout the
whole kind of process from the candidate
management's the client management and
everything in between
because it's so easy for something to
slip through the gaps and for you to
miss something that's going to come back
to bite you later
um and seconds that probably the best
advice i could give myself would be not
to spend the commission until i receive
it
because yeah you're always living kind
of a couple of paychecks in advance
going away i'm gonna have a big month
and uh yeah that can come back to bite
you if you've not been for her and
obviously something
something adverse has happened as a
result yeah
and and on on that and and then we'll
sort of start talking about sort of
overall your
sort of billing career as an employee
but like just on that because we hear
this a lot on here like trust the
process don't let things slip through
the gap
obviously you've been in a leadership
capacity in your
um obviously the last company you work
for leading a team
where do you think and i guess you can
draw on any part of your
journey really but where do you think so
recruiters maybe early on in their
career can sometimes
let things slip you think throughout the
process out of interest just to go a bit
more deeper and practical on that
yeah it's just the just the attention to
the
the finer parts of the detail you know
um i think
most businesses every business at least
i've been a part of you know have a
certain way of doing things
um from candidate registration and
through to client you know kind of
taking a job order and
everything in there in between so it's
just making sure that you are 100
fuller on that you know you you're not
just taking necessarily people's first
answers
um you know you you're exploring that in
a little bit more detail i mean
something
some things that would bite me back in
you know back way back when would be
you know somebody would say look i'm
happy to relocate and i'd be like
brilliant relocate i'm gonna say
because you're gonna relocate relocation
yeah exactly but then it's it's going
that's you know that next line of
questioning okay so what's the
practicalities behind that what's your
lease agreement like whether you've got
family have you got children do you have
to take them out of school do you have
to do this and it's just
understanding you know the reality
behind the dream i suppose because
sometimes it's like this guy looks
amazing he's amazing he's gonna extend
him he's gonna get the job
and again it's because i probably didn't
want to know that level of detail
because
you know in my head i just thought he
was you know they were good enough for
it
yeah yeah then so look let's just talk
about
your sort of uh yeah billing career as a
whole
and before you started your own business
and
i guess look as i said you before we
started this
most recruiters that we speak to um
and when we try and find out from them
sort of where they are today and where
they want to go
when we um when they join the the
community
most people will say and put down that
they want to be the top biller
right um and as i mentioned in this
introduction
um you managed to hold that title
sort of back to back when you was a okra
hampton
in 2018 2019 right
so i think look fair to say
recruitment's
um a really competitive environment
internally as well as
externally so let's try and unpack that
and there'll be different things that we
can go into but i guess my first
question for you really is
obviously loads of competition
internally like why why do you think you
was able to
achieve that within that business do you
think
what did you do differently i think
there was a couple a couple of different
kind of reasons i mean just being
completely frank and honest um
you know my performance whilst i was in
my first two companies it started off
strong
it probably plateaued a little bit um
probably got a little bit complacent and
then it was coming into
my last role really where things started
accelerating there's a couple of
different reasons as to
that sort of couple of sort of changes
probably i made in terms of
my own process um to kind of help
escalate that but
you know i just knew i i was probably
more focused than i'd ever been
in knowing what i wanted to achieve i'm
breaking that down into into chunks of
okay this is what i need to do and this
is this is you know where i need to be
by
by this day and so on and so forth so i
kind of worked backwards from my end
goal
um but trying to stick to that as
rigidly as possible i suppose
um but yeah a kind of a big a big change
in pivot for me was
um in the way that i try to attract
candidates
so historically i mean you know i was
doing
probably you know 120 130k a push
um you know in in a market that i'd been
in for quite a while
um and i was really really relying on
the tools that i was provided so i was
relying on the job boards i was relying
on
um yeah pretty much the job boards
yeah yeah and just really kind of um you
know looking there and
and to be fair the amount of offers i
had versus
the amount of business that actually
stuck um was ridiculous you know i was
missing out on
on 90k in a year of offers that didn't
end up landing
um and i i suppose just to give a bit
background on the on
just a quick snippet of the journey we
went i went and did the
um did a recruitment out in america for
a while and that we didn't have the same
tools we had available when we when i
was working in
in a london market that i was familiar
with so um i had to
to really kind of develop new methods of
reaching candidates a lot more kind of
head hunting
i'm calling people in the office using
reliably more heavily reliant on
linkedin
so when i came back to to the uk to kind
of pick up where i'd left off
i can now came back to that market with
a new set of skills
um and that just or immediately that
that that small pivot small change in in
the way that i went about my business
made a massive massive impact because it
meant that those offers that i was
generating still
were sticking because the candidates
that i was finding um you know had been
purposefully head hunted rather than
being the best available at that time
yeah okay so let's talk about that
appreciate you
filling us in there on the context so
just to add to that how long was you in
america for
so it was it was only six months um so i
i didn't actually get a chance to
to move out there because i was pending
marriage with my wife at the time
um and yeah unfortunately i didn't i
wasn't i wasn't physically on the ground
but i was working remotely and
i did go and spend some time in our la
office as well nice so
so basically what you're sharing with us
then is that yeah like you really added
the sort of um added a lot more tools to
your
to your toolbox in terms of the way of
doing things so i really appreciate the
honesty in that so let's just break that
down a bit so when you say
head hunting and calling people in your
office i'll get that
um like just talk to us a bit about like
what that actually looks like and why
why is that then
ended up working for you is it because
you're literally directly calling people
and going hey
i'm currently working with an
organization that has actually told me
that
they want you in their business like i
don't know just talk to us a bit about
that actual approach
yeah so it's less probably cloak and
dagger um
you know i think when i was when i was
trained on how to do that at least when
people told me it was always the carrot
and the stick type situation so it was
always go in there and make them feel
kind of you know they've been
individually you know selected by
by the employer um but that's that's not
the that's not the case so
i've always gone down one well in with
an honesty approach when it comes to it
comes to head hunting but
um it's more for me been about mapping
mapping out businesses because what i
really what i realized as well is
a keyword searching a boolean search is
fantastic it's going to give you all
these great developers and stuff to look
at but naturally
you know if they're coming up in your
search they're coming up in everyone
else's search
so it was more it was more understanding
okay brilliant so if this guy's working
at this company with this
this skill set then sure enough there's
going to be more people in that company
because some people
when you're trying to identify them on
linkedin their presence is very minimal
states of employment they may not you
know even have you know any keywords or
anything like that but they're still
probably equally as good if not
potentially better than the people that
are coming in
up in your search that do have a more
profound
and flushed out linkedin profile
presence online
so it was more about kind of mapping
companies and understanding where
the the hotspot hotspots were for the
skills i was looking for
and then as i say making those
introductions quite directly on the
phone
my process has always been um to achieve
a little
um but a lot of times if that makes
sense
yeah so not to go into a headhunting
call
with the objection of of of winning a
candidate over and selling them the
dream on that call
going going into that call with a
simpler objective of getting a mobile
number from them to give them a call
back after work when it's more
convenient
nice that that yeah so switch the
objective
that's interesting because i guess
you're you're more motivated to make
those calls because
it's not a failure if you don't get a
yes on and talk to you about that job
it's just more of
would you would you mind give it give us
um would you mind
just talking a bit because i know people
love this sort of stuff yep
would you mind just sharing a bit around
like the script
yes what's like the opener basically if
you call me
i'm sitting on my desk i'm someone that
you know
at some point there's a good chance that
there'll be jobs that
i might be open to i've got the right
skill set like you catch me at work
obviously it's a completely different
environment now so it'd be good to get
your thoughts on how this has changed
but
if i'm in the office and you get my
number you call me directly what what's
that what's the opening what's the
opening yeah
i mean firstly hopefully you'll be able
to hear me because i try and just do as
quick and elevate a pitch as possible
so um because i'm very conscious that
when you go when you land on that desk
phone
they might be sending to the cto you
might be interrupting
scrum me in you know anything they could
you don't know what's going on around
you so
i try and encourage them to speak as
little as possible
so my two objectives are then to say
probably to speak twice on the call
um the first time is to acknowledge that
that's them who i'm speaking to
to make sure i'm not pitching their boss
and the second
the second objective is is to agree for
a call back and and hopefully get an
alternative contact number from them if
i am calling them on the desk line or or
what have you so my normal introduction
to that would be quick
just a very quick introduction to myself
so be hi you know i'm nathan donnell i'm
giving you a call from source control
um straight away i mean you know sorry i
apologize it was
firstly asking if that sh i'd say hi is
that james yeah yeah
james yeah hi it's nathan donnelly i'm
pretty much from source control
and then straight into the micro pitch
which is just look look um the reason
i'm giving you a call today i'm a
specialist technical headhunter
i specialize in this area very very
quick glazing over there
but then bring it straight back to a
personalization about them because
i mean if i'm going in there cold with
no information then they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna detect that
straight away so it's more identifying
because
you know at this point you've got the
linkedin profile hopefully in front of
them you can see something about them
and it's picking
on a certain unique selling point about
them
that you can sell back to them to show
that you well researched to show that
you've done your homework and you're
genuinely interested in having that
conversation
that can range from oh brilliant i can
see you've been at x company for
five years now you know that's really
really impressive look i just wanted to
speak to you about this it could be
actually you know i see you working with
xyz technology that's that really
interests me
a lot of people as well you'll notice
when you're browsing lots and lots of
linkedin profiles
you know people like to give information
people like are passionate about what
they're doing
and they and they will they you know
they'll detail that in their profile so
it might be that
they're working with x y and z
technology but
they've mentioned you know i've got an
interest in this if you've got a
position that
you know will will play on that interest
then it's about letting them know about
that
but again it's probably up diluted it a
little bit there in terms of the context
but
it's a very quick introduction so i know
that was really helpful
yeah the key there is the
personalization bit
yeah it is it's just it's just making it
but it's also showing empathy as well so
what so as i say once i've quickly
introduced myself
as soon as they hear technical
headhunter um straight away you know
nerves are probably going to come up you
know
the hairs on the back of the neck you
know they're even heavier because the
cto as i say or whoever's stood near
them
um you know straight away defuse now
look i'm really apologize for calling
you so directly at work
the reason i'm calling you and then it's
the justification
back then to the empathy at the end
again i apologize for contacting you
directly
however i would love to have a
conversation with you outside of
business hours
look what's the best way for me to reach
you simple as that is that is that the
clue is that the like closure of like
just saying hey
yeah yeah it's just you know it's
basically as i say that pitch from start
to finish
you know will generally last about 30
seconds so yeah
they're having to pick up the phone and
hopefully they can walk away from that
without
you know somebody going oh who was that
because you know they've not had to
answer anything they can just say oh
rubbish officers it was nothing because
i found if you start to ask them and
open them up they straight away close
down so it flows down yeah that's really
good
how did you get the mobile then that's
it so i'll ask him look do you have an
alternative number i can call you back
on
um you know sometimes nine times i would
say well five times out of ten they'll
just give you the number just to get you
off the phone and then you call back at
five o'clock and they've got no interest
in it whatsoever but at least you've got
you know that that channel of
communications opened up and you know
yeah
and you can start to build on that
because as i say with headhunting
it's not an overnight job not everyone's
going to be looking straight away yeah
and but the more you do it the
the wider your network gets and you know
those are the really good
the really good candidates to have that
you can just draw back on you know
months and months later and think
who did i speak to about that and then
you can go back because you know they're
not they're passive candidates at the
end of the day so
you know you knock back on that door
again this time you've got the personal
number hopefully you're saying look i'm
just recalling our conversation six
months
ago um remember you mentioned this i've
got now this opportunity
and hopefully you know it goes from
there yeah yeah no
thank you so much for going into so much
detail and then look as we're on there
so i know we're going into deep diveness
but i know
people like the real practical things
how
how has this approach changed
yeah we've lost that yeah like how
because obviously i think
i'm sure it's changing now like a real
common
sort of work dynamic seems like a hybrid
approach but i'm sure there's a lot of
people still doing remote so
i don't know how have you sort of been
flexible with that
it's um it's become a lot more expensive
just in terms of how to kind of
aggregate data and get the day because
obviously
you know there's a plethora of tools out
there um available
um you know for you to utilize um on
subscription basis free basis whatever
you know
that's a sales ql lushers um all of
these kind of tools ai databases which
can scrape and
aggregate data but the you know the
simple fact of the matter is it's tough
you know if they're not at work and you
can't get through them you've got to go
in
you know you've got to again variate
your style and try something new
um the massive massive rise that i've
seen a big big pivotal change
and that i've noticed that i've had to
try and adapt as much as possible as i
can do
is more about the outbound and email
marketing um
you know how to personalize approaches
there and as i say
you know it's not hand on heart it's not
my strongest suit
i can deliberate over an email for 20
minutes thinking
is this going to hit the mark you know
and and again i've sat next to people
that
you know within a couple you know two
three minutes they've written something
amazing that's really good and captures
the attention
um so again it's it's constantly just
trying to you know
add to your artillery really and try
constantly trying to build and improve
but
there has been a huge seismic shift i
would say in terms of how to
how you can contact people it go it's
it's
two ways though because at the end of
the day if you can get the contact
information up to the two
you know for them the chances are they
are sat at home so they can take the
call
so it takes away that that awkwardness
straight away
so you can yeah may ask more open
questions and yeah
hopefully normally yes the conversation
will
will possibly last more than 30 seconds
because they might they might go okay
yeah we're going to talk right now
which is brilliant yeah yeah sure okay
interesting so
obviously what you shared there and why
we spoke about that was because
before you had that experience in
america where you was building things
from scratch
you being very honest and saying look i
i was bidding 120 130 grand a year and a
lot of the time i was using job boards
and that means i was mainly tapping into
the job seeker market which also meant
that i'm assuming
yeah you got more offers but a lot of
these people were obviously getting
other offers
as well right um so what you've shared
of us is that
you added you added this tool to your
toolbox and it had a real impact
um i guess let's just let's just title
together then so when you
um got the top um biller award what did
you end up billing and then i want to
speak to you about
the client side because that's always
something that people want to um
talk about and want to improve so let's
just just put that into context
yeah i mean i i think in the first year
joining the business
kind of february to december and it was
about 185
k um offering accepted um we ran about
160 started which again isn't you know
it's not
you know it's not life-changing numbers
in a lot of different industries
um
the best year that you had when you're
on the top builder was just under 200
grand
no but since the year following that
again right you know it was
in excess of 200 000 but i think i
brought a kind of a little bit of a chip
on my shoulder
um because i had leaving one company and
and having
you know done six months in america in a
new market that kind of
didn't really reflect you know what my
capabilities were
over a 12-month period in a in a
consistent market
so when i was interviewing for the job
maybe i embellished something slightly
by you know 5 or 10k here or there in
terms of what i was capable of so
i knew that going into that business
i've got now a target on my head and i
put that target on my own head so this
is
this is the the level i said i can
deliver at so now i need to deliver at
that level
and it's it was more knowing it's again
i i kind of look at it as a glass
ceiling
in terms of you know you you totally
capable everyone's
i've seen lots of people really over
exceed um
on regular occasions because you know
that it's it's limiting belief that will
stop you from potentially
going that next step further and going
from that one deal to two deals to three
deals a month
um yeah that's that's really interesting
and then
so i guess talking about the the client
side
spoke a lot around the candidate piece
um
this seems to be the area that typically
recruiters will share and it's a lot of
the questions that i get on like where
people want to improve
um it's it seems so what's been your
journey with
bringing on clients and and winning
business like how have you improved in
that department was there anything else
that you sort of
really opened up to so i'm assuming in
america you had to win business and
stuff anything that
you sort of improved on which you wasn't
doing early on in your career that's had
a ruined patch you think
yeah i mean you know it's experience
accounts for quite a lot you know you do
this job day in day out and so naturally
you know you refine things that name
maybe didn't work so well in the past
and improve upon things and
and get more confident as well in terms
of in terms of what you're doing first
and foremost but also the cell
um for bd for me i've always been
quite um quite phone centric so i've
always been
quite cold call led quite um you know
just
calling up not necessarily when there's
even any business there you know so not
not chasing leads i just have a big list
of people that i want to want to speak
to because i know that they're in my
industry
um and it's it's one of them it's just
understanding that
they're you know there's you need
multiple touch points i suppose
you know sometimes you can get on a call
and brilliant you win a job
first time and you're like you know it's
most of the time when that happens i'm
scrambling for a pen because i'm just
not expecting it you know going to
introduce yourself they're like okay i'm
going to take a job spec now and you i'm
roughing around and
i'm trying to get the linkedin up at the
same time um but yeah
i think for me i've kind of the way the
way i've i've thrived is by having
um i suppose a fairly close knit
group of clients that i know are regular
hirers
um and i have to you know i i still do
and maintain you know a good level of bd
consistently
um but i would normally gravitate
towards
um you know a pool of clients that i've
built good relationships with
and that i kind of can grow on and
expand on um
and that that they can then trust me
with delivery rather than it being
you know because a lot of bd i suppose
going into it is
i i promise you i can do this you know i
swear
i'm going to give you the best
candidates and and x y and z
and and selling them the dream but um i
think really
um where bd is where i suppose i've had
i've grown and seen the most benefit is
is from
um growing those client relationships
over time delivering on your word and
being consistent with it as well
and as i said not over stretching
yourself sometimes you find a losing
battle
um and you know it's it's it's difficult
because as a leader i've been told
you know to to be fairly cut throat with
with people and be certain to be saying
okay well look that's not yielding any
results move on
move on and um sometimes you know it's
it's hard to take your own advice
because as i say you know if you if you
work and invest into something
you know um and you and you make that
progress with it it's hard to sometimes
walk away from it and think and cut your
losses and go actually no this isn't the
right company or
opportunity or the conditions aren't
right but um
again i don't know if this is kind of
going away from the point but
it's more than the bet the stronger
relationship that you have with
a client company whatever the more
influence you have
it's very hard to jump into a
recruitment process
and start telling them how to do their
job or child to change things that's
going to
necessarily benefit you or the candidate
or what have you
but once you once you've worked
consistently with people
they know your abilities and they know
what you can do they're much more
receptive
to to take your influence and your
guidance
on things that you can change extradite
um you know
sometimes even remove entirely um you
know to make the process more fluid
yeah no thank you and i guess what we're
talking about here which which i i'm
going to ask you
just to go a bit more deeper because i
think this is what a lot of people will
really benefit from
because what you're talking about there
is you like where you've really improved
is
sort of getting away from doing just
spot business people call it or
for a worse analogy just one night
stands right with businesses
you do that and then as you said you
make you may leave that relationship
with credibility
because you're delivered on your word
but if you're not doing any other
business with them then there's
still lack of influence i don't know i
don't know what sort of relationship
that is
maybe it's still a bit more
transactional whereas what you're
talking about is
yeah actually working with maybe less
clients and making sure that these
clients
know that you're the person that can
support them with their growth
your building relationships and then as
you said you can then
sort of impact and influence the process
which not only benefits them but
benefits
you and and obviously attracting people
and taking people through that process
i think this is something that i'm
hearing a lot from recruiters where also
again
they feel like they they need to improve
because i think it's very easy to
get excited by that so by those terms
getting signed and then it can be on to
the next one
right or i'm always looking so i guess
what what i'm just keen to
ask you is i guess yeah how have you got
better one at sort of
identifying businesses that you think
could
make for a great uh relationship long
term that you
i'm assuming will get more confident in
spending more time with them because you
feel like
in the long term there will be more than
just one higher two highs etc
and then two um yeah just talk a bit
about
we always hear this word relationship
but like how can recruiters listen to
this actually
build related like long-term
relationships with their
their clients like how do we actually do
that um
but yeah that's what i was kind of here
yeah i mean you know when it comes to
kind of establishing obviously a kind of
target audience and target list of
clients i mean that that's kind of you
know recruitment 101 is knowing your
audience
um you know it's taking the time when
you're building a market because
naturally
most people are coming into cold markets
swapping markets markets have not been
in the past it's
it's doing your due diligence knowing
who the players are the big moves and
shakers are in
you know in your industry and always
having that kind of list of of priority
clients that you would love to crack
into
um you know it's my my old kind of black
male boss used to always kind of really
drill into our heads that it was
you know the six touch points um you
know with any client you know
no as as time goes on you know if you
keep knocking on that door
you know after six times hopefully it's
going to open for you
um whereas most people get disinterested
for the third knock you know they'll and
they'll kind of they'll abandon it
but it's the people that are
consistently knocking and knocking and
knocking to the
you know eventually even if it's to tell
you to bugger off you know they're still
going to answer that
at some point just just quickly on this
sorry to button
yep first thing again just i think
you're doing a really great job of
keeping it's really practical one i know
it may seem really basic and simple to
you but one
how like how do you keep track of like
like i know you say market map and it's
simple but like how do you do that out
of interest
like is it are you set up with
notifications in industry
news and like i don't know just just one
on that and then two
you hear these six points in seven
points 12 points or whatever
but like i think people sort of
sometimes are unsure on like what to
knock with
yeah i mean so it's like yeah so just
that's what i just wanted to ask you
sorry to button
yeah yeah no i mean i've just you
slipped my mind the first question you
wanted you just mentioned next i was
focused on the second question so what
was the first one again
the first one was just like i know it
may seem not really second nature to you
but you said
keeping track of like the top thing so
how do you actually do that out of
interest like what have been there
again you know for if i if i've had to
do throughout my career
start start lots of lots of new markets
so
especially at my time at oakwell and
when i was just prior to leaving i was
kind of hot bedding markets for new
consultants to come into so i kind of go
in there get them off the ground and my
first
my first point of call would be um cv
stripping you know getting on linkedin
getting getting just putting putting
basic boolean on searches in to find the
skills that are attractive to my market
audience
and then going through those companies
um you know one by one and
meticulously adding them to a database
or what have you
what i've found since then is you know
that and i suppose
a couple of other tools there's a wealth
of different tools and available out
there in the market that help to give
you that edge and insight
um things like talent ticker for example
sauce break
you know all these kind of things that
hopefully if you're working you know you
know a
you know a fairly sized or a decent
organization you know you'll have access
to one or two of them
um you know looking at linkedin link to
news feeds
um you know making sure you've got
alerts and watchdogs set up for hiring
trends
in your in your demographic um you know
all those kind of things so the
information it's not something that gets
it's overnight it's something that you
you know will build and build and build
yeah
as you know as you it's it's all really
exciting you come into a new market
okay you type in don and developers and
all of a sudden
you know there's 500 vacancies have just
been posted
like brilliant at kidney candy shop
there's loads and loads of companies
that i can go after now
um but you have to do that you know
you're doing that search every
day every week you know for the rest of
the time that you're in that market and
you'll slowly notice that
you know that that that list is no
longer 500 there's only five or ten
fresh ones that are coming up every week
so but it's the ones
it's identifying the ones that are
consistently there the ones that are
always hiring and such like that and
just making making some
sort of notes of it um when you talk
about obviously the
you know breaking down those six touch
points so again
it's it's phone conversation i i've
always been predominantly phone led
but it's so my first touch point would
always be a phone call um you know see
if i can
if i can firstly get through to them if
i do brilliant then you know
introducing myself seeing how far that
will get with you know i can get with
that
then it's backing that up with an email
which is a service overview you know
look thank you for your time brilliant
um you know i had a great time talking
to you this is this is who i am this is
what i do
and then it's just the following up
again because you know you might call
them again three weeks later a month
later two months later whatever that may
be whatever you've agreed with them at
the time
um and the doorman can still be closed
but again it's following again up with
an email
um after that call and then just being
regular in it and just
repeat you know there's no exact science
to it because
there's so much look sometimes that's
involved with recruitment as well
it it can be the right timing but you
know the more you put the more
opportunities you you know the more you
contact them and the more
you're there the more opportunities
hopefully you're gonna create for
yourself
and if not today but tomorrow um and
they will remember you because
you know the first call i make to
somebody um
it's brief they tell me that they're not
interested brilliant okay
i know and within within a week i've
been forgotten about 100
but then i call back three weeks ago and
i reference you know it's about
taking i suppose even if it's a small
but taking
a bit of one one piece of information as
a minimum from each call
and building on that out each time so it
could be
you know i just say okay brilliant look
i know you're working with recruiters at
the moment just out of curiosity
you know what what what do you normally
work to recruitments like with
recruiters that they might say 15
percent i make a note about the next
call
oh look like you know last time we spoke
you mentioned that you're working with
some recruiters at 15
you know and it's just dropping that in
and it's giving giving context to the
information that you've accumulated that
then starts triggering by the time you
call them for the fourth time
like all right nathan look there's no
more jobs i've told you before
but they remember you you know it's just
about getting them to remember you
because then
hopefully the fifth time when everyone
else has given up they go actually
something's just come up
um yeah yeah i've been meaning to reach
out because you know there's an
opportunity there so
again it's it's making sure that you i
suppose in summary
you were you you going into every call
with the objective of taking something
away from every goal
yeah nice and that's what i was just
looking for yeah for that
because i think that's the sometimes
what people are unsure of isn't it is
like okay well
i called this person last time and
nothing really happens like what do i
call them about what's the reason for my
call
so i think so thank you for sharing that
and then i guess the
the other part then is the
and then so let's say you did all of
that they give you that job
they deliver it's a company that you've
mapped out on and confident
are on the right track there's growth
what what i don't know how do you then
think about
sort of building on that relationship
you know like i don't know what are
things we
obviously need to deliver that's firstly
that's gonna obviously really
start building this relationship but i
don't know anything else that has really
helped you in the past
take a relationship where it's maybe a
bit transactional to start to
sort of solid yeah i mean it comes down
to me for for me aware is being as
fuller as possible from that initial job
order because
given that when sometimes when you get
given the opportunity to take a job
order
yeah they're giving you the opportunity
but they don't really want to give you
the opportunity because they're not
willing to sit down and spend
the right amount of time to tell you
what they actually want they go you've
got the job spec don't you 15
sounds all right doesn't it all right
look do what what do you need to know
you know
but it's i suppose just kind of taking
control early on of that
of that job order and and really trying
to understand and get as much
information
about the business because essentially
you know you are a brand ambassador
for that company when you work on their
behalf you know you're the one that's
out there selling that and
and that that also helps as well when
you when you're looking to head on
people because the better you can sell
an opportunity
you know the more interested you're
going to have people that are they're
essentially in that opportunity so
from day one it's i suppose you know
it's taking
making sure you're setting up the
meetings you know unless it's thrown
upon you
where you're setting them up with an
object you know a kind of a couple of
objectives that you want to achieve on
that call
um as part of the job order process
digging deeper
on not just necessarily what is now the
next you know the need right now but
what it looks like in the future and
it's then it's just cultivating you know
brilliant after you've done the
placement you know lots of people will
be like invoices sent now
passed the rebate brilliant but it's
about keeping those touch points open
just checking in with you house house so
and so settling in right now you know
what impact have they had in the team
keeping on the radar brilliant
by the way are you looking for anyone
else in the future um you know what's it
what's
you know just trying to find out what
what's exciting is happening in the
business
um because you know lots of times
they'll be really happy to tell you
these things but people just don't ask
the questions
you know and people especially when
people you know are passionate about the
businesses that they're working in you
know it's like oh actually you know
it's funny you should ask that because
something really exciting is happening
i'm just around the corner we're
expecting to get all this new funding
um you know whatever that could be um
but it's just
it's the the place is keeping consistent
after the placement and and you know and
just keeping those
those those channels of communication
not so you become a hindrance
because obviously you do a good job and
then you send them an email every week
with speculative candidates you know
they're not hiring for
that can become a burden for them that
can become an annoyance for them
and and i've had it in the past you know
where the doors have shut because they
said look brilliant you gave us a
brilliant candidate
but your pistons off now because you
won't leave us alone you know what i
mean and
we've told you so it's it's being
pragmatic and practical about it as well
and
and um just listening for those key
those key indicators and just
asking the right questions i think um
but yeah
the more questions you ask the more
you're gonna know yeah no awesome
so look keen to talk to talk about
um your business journey so far in the
last sort of 15 minutes or so
but i know we've kept this really
practical um
which i think is great and will really
help people listening to this the final
thing that
i'd really like to go sort of practical
on
is self management time management
prioritization whatever you want to call
it
is something that again speaking to so
many recruiters has really come apparent
that a lot of recruiters can struggle
with this
and i think what's really happened which
we were talking before this that people
have got
really busy maybe not every once if
you're not sorry
but a lot of people have said that
they're they've got really busy so now
it's like oh my god
like what do i need to prioritize that's
going to enable me to hit my goals and
just getting better at that and every
time i speak to
sort of top billers and high performers
on this they've really got this
nailed down and i think if i think early
back when i started then
maybe you can agree or not but that
that's definitely something that
typically don't always i don't remember
getting any support and i just had to
learn
the hard way and find out what other
people did did they do email
reminders and like how did they
structure their day and just just learn
as i went so i guess
a lot of people and a real common
question i get is please heating can you
ask
top builders what their sort of daily
schedule look like or what their
structure look like
when they're at the top of their game
compared to when they're early on and
maybe
sort of um still um yeah earning their
stripes and finding it difficult so what
what does self management look like for
you
yeah i mean sometimes you know look i'm
completely honest sometimes it's
organized chaos
um you know sometimes there's like a lot
more of a rigid structure to it i mean
for myself um kind of kind of looking
looking back
from maybe some of the kind of habitual
changes that i i've made
um throughout throughout the time um
would be
probably more around the organizer you
know just the basics of organizations so
the calendaring things as well
setting tasks setting reminders because
if i don't do that i will forget
yeah um i'm i'm very much a paper-based
guy
so i'll be scribbling down loads and
loads of notes and then i'm ripping that
piece of paper off and that's going over
there and then
it's gone you know i mean my wife's
coming to the room or someone's picked
up
and throw it away and then i've lost
that vital information so
it's being you know it's being organized
in terms of you know calendarization
putting things putting things
into schedules and also really
importantly for me as well was was
making sure that
i'm being you know putting it as
comprehensive and notes as possible
on write-ups in terms of everything that
i've done from the candidates through to
the clients
uh you know conversations i'm having
with them just so um
you know because it's very easy just to
shorthand something and pop it on there
and forget about something that might be
important um
but going back in in terms of kind of in
terms of like
the actual how to organize my day
i think historically i've tried
everything you know i've tried
really really strict day structures
where
from 9 30 to 10 o'clock i'm doing
linkedin messaging and from 10 o'clock
to 11 o'clock i'm doing this and i
always fail really hard at it because
naturally you know you've got the best
intentions going into something
but you know it it's in recruitment
things change at the drop of a hat all
of a sudden a job order comes through or
you know you're on a candidate calls in
or something you know
something changes basically which will
deviate away from
what you had intended and because of
that kind of
rigidness sometimes in the in the goals
i'd set myself for the for the day i'd
walk away from that day and think
you know what i've really failed that
day yeah yeah i didn't do
kind of i didn't stick to my structure
um so now i think when i
when i look back to when i've been you
know kind of my best peaks of
performance so to speak
generally it's um it's quite systematic
in terms of knowing
what i need to achieve for each each
individual client
um and what i want to get out of a week
um out of a kind of a
from a bd strategy so when i look at
that i look at daily goals and weekly
goals
okay so so i would break things down
like
um okay so this i've got this job and
you know i've not got much coverage on
it so
i need to find today my targets to find
two good cvs for that role that that i
want or two good headhunts that role
that i want to get i want to get shipped
out
and then my wider goal for the week
would be okay i want two new two new
jobs as well so i want two new clients
so i'm working to get working on smaller
goals and larger goals simultaneously
because if i say to myself i'm gonna get
a job today and i don't get that job
today
i'm gonna walk away from that day
feeling really bad but if i give myself
an extra bit of breathing room i think
on a weekly basis okay this is what i
want to accomplish this week
um then you know the peaks and troughs
that you go through hopefully
you know you'll get as close to if not
hitting or over achieving
those goals that you've set out um i
think it's in particular with with
the candidate stuff it's what i used to
fall into
the trap of was probably not giving
getting enough coverage
on um on on jobs so i would go out to
market with loads of enthusiasm
and i'd find them someone that i thought
was really really good and then i'd send
him off and i think he's got the job and
then that would be that
um yeah yeah for me it's uh and then it
turns out that they
they're not they weren't as good as i
thought they were um or for one reason
or over it wasn't a good fit for them
vice versa what whatever it may be but
for now
now i would kind of work to a structure
of
this is now my focus for this amount of
time so i'm going to do this
i've set myself a target of the free tvs
i'm not going to look at another search
until i've got the free seed beats
because then at least i can walk
i can walk away from that search with
confidence that i've got three
people in the process and that will give
me enough time you know
with them hopefully that would be we
used to work on on a rule of
a rule of three where this kind of i
don't know who created the statistics i
think i think my director i think my
director literally made it up
to make it sound better at the time but
it was always um if you can get free
interviews for a role
you know you'd be like 90 percent higher
chance of you feeling it than if you
just get one interview and obviously
kind of work towards that so again
slightly
long way of saying it um
just just really quickly because i think
this is like how do you i think the
important part that you meant there is
like you anchored the time to it because
i think what
you can be quite susceptible to early on
on just overall is like
like you said my goal is two cvs but
it's like okay well how long am i going
to give myself to
to get that and i think you can fall
down the rabbit hole then of like
just doing one thing for like too long
but i don't know do you like anchorage
you mentioned they're like i would
generally you know i generally kind of
set my objective for that day
and so and again again so it's i
normally plan
you know the day before for the day
ahead um so it's like the last 15
minutes of my day it's like reflection
on what i've
done and what have i achieved then it's
a kind of a you know looking forward to
what what do i want to do tomorrow um
but again you know things are subject to
change
you know sometimes you know things are
out because you control
you know things that seem easy aren't
easy and you know you have to you know
you sometimes you have to abandon ship
because you know
your time naturally especially when
you're when you're a consultant working
for somebody else there's a hell of a
lot of pressure
you know there's a hell of a lot of
pressure to deliver because you know the
rules there's always that saying in
recruitment you're only as good as your
last month and you're always looking
over your shoulder slightly to think
like okay
you know okay last one for me wasn't as
good as i walked but this one's going to
be very good
so it's just no i suppose for me it's
just
in terms of allotting the time it's it's
either till
you think you've done a good enough job
or until you've exhausted it enough to
know that
that's probably as much as you can do
yeah i think
the key that you've said there is to
make sure that you make space to like
review
yeah because instead of going i'm not
going to stop until i've got free
interviews like okay well how long does
that go on for like you've got a
i think that's the key thing isn't it
because sometimes i could just keep
going and then all of a sudden
my whole week is spent on this job and
i've got
two interviews rather than three but i
haven't yeah reviewed and made time to
prioritize anything else
just to add to that i mean i do kind of
pivot so you know i won't
i'll set myself an objective for that
day that this is gonna be my focus
client for the day and i'm gonna
i'm gonna look to get coverage but with
that naturally by
the way that we're interacting with
candidates whether it's via email in
mail
linkedin messages connections and stuff
like that that you know it's a it's a
bottleneck really there's a lot of
a lot of energy that goes in and what
comes out
doesn't necessarily come out straight
away so even you know you can sit there
at the end of the day and you can think
jesus didn't even manage to reg one
person today you know and and kind of
give yourself a hard time
but the work that you've done will come
and pay back you know pay for itself
in the days to come because you know
that that bottleneck will start to unjam
and you get those candidates that you
sent the message to a couple of days ago
that you know maybe overlooked it or
maybe it's just more appropriate times
than reply to then start coming back to
you so
yeah when i when i say that my
objectives are to get the two tvs
my objectives my objectives more are to
work the hell out of that position
and then probably the next day focus on
to something else because as i said
there's always a kind of lapse in time
when you're dealing you know
with people essentially yeah yeah things
things don't happen to click
you know you know click your fingers
unfortunately yeah
so look what i'm um what i'm thinking um
nath is that let's not let's not half
bake the uh
the business journey let's get you back
on when further down like we've spoken
for a whole hour
and real practical one obviously you're
still recruiting right so like this is
this is you this is
how you approach things this isn't like
employee now business owner like you're
you're smashing out
on your own but i guess real quick like
um what what has sort of happened so far
or what have you experienced so far
as a business owner that you least
didn't expect maybe
and we'll ask that question yeah back
office
you know i mean it's something you take
for granted and you're thinking well it
mustn't be that hard
you know to do these things and it's
just um
yeah there's a hell of a lot of stuff
kind of happens when you when you when
you flick that switch and there's so
many things you have to be mindful of
and
you know for me just in the in the free
foot in the four months or so that i've
been
um a business owner um it has been an
absolute baptism of fire
um i've had to think on my feet a lot
quicker than i have done in the past
i've had to learn very quickly
um and i've had to adjust you know and
the positives that come away from that
is
you know what when your names on the
door i suppose the the kind of passion
enthusiasm you have really does
um kind of echo through to the people
that you're engaging with because
you know it's your baby essentially um
so
so yeah it's um in back office so what
when you say back office what do you
mean are we talking accounts are we
talking
like just yeah i mean it's all you know
simple things you coming to a
recruitment company your first day
you've got your own mugs out there
you've got your laptops now
you've got your email account all done
all your logins are sorted and you know
that's all taken care of and brilliant
i'm gonna log in here i'm gonna
get to work but obviously it's the it's
the negotiating behind that
it's all the invoicing it's it's praying
to god that people pay you on time
because obviously in recruitment if
you're working for somebody else you
know regardless if they pay or not
you're getting your commission check
then
yeah you forget that i don't know yeah
even if the invoice hasn't been paid yet
yeah
exactly any good recruitment company is
going to pay you regardless so it's more
kind of like you know sitting on your
hands being very patient and stuff and
and yeah just trying to trying to manage
all the all the noise because as well
you know i'm always on the selling end
of you know
when i have work for somebody else and
now i'm very much on the receiving end
as well whereas a lot of people with a
lot of services a lot of improvements
and
you know a lot of chats virtual coffees
that people want to have to improve my
business performance and x y and zed so
yeah it's uh it's a bit of a minefield
at times but it's been a good journey so
far
nice as i said we'll we'll get you back
on and we'll really dive into that
um but look i've got some quick fire
questions to finish this
but before i do you've um creighton if
i'm wrong but have you always been a
permanent recruiter
yeah so predominantly throughout my
career has been permanent i have dual
desk done on various occasions if
someone gives me a contract i'll bite
your hand off
you know for it um but yeah
predominantly just
my kind of talent my strategy is
permanent yeah so
before i go into these quick file
questions the the question i wanted to
ask you was
what what do you think is like the most
important thing
a perm recruiter needs to master
and and why i would say candidate
control
yeah because i look yeah i think
contracts recruiters
you know they are they are a special
breed especially
very good contract recruiters everything
is so fast-paced and so fast-moving
um but you know so were the interviews
sometimes at the con you know your
contracts uh
they go in for a 15-minute chat and they
walk out with a job getting paid five
six hundred pounds a day
whereas you know you could have someone
on the permanent that only wants 30
grand and i'll have to go through five
stages of interview process
you know because they're becoming a
permanent member of that team so it's
from being
really really fuller with the candidate
acquisition process so from how you
how you engage with them to really
asking as i say and not shying away from
those tough questions
um you know the stuff that you don't
want to hear and i suppose
really really importantly as well um is
constantly and can't stress enough
really going back over and being as full
as possible
with what else they've got going on
because things change very quickly
and you can ask them on the monday
whatever interviews have you got have
you got anything that you expect to turn
into an offer and they say oh no and
everything's at the first stage and she
speaks on a tuesday and i've accepted an
offer
so it's it's it's trying to open them up
and
and as i say be as personable as
possible so that you know they're
forthcoming with that information they
don't feel that you know you're prying
that for your advantage
um but the best way you can help people
is is by understanding them you know
understanding their needs as best
possible because
as i say they could have you know you
could have a really really good
opportunity for them but time is
on your side so it's just trying to
understand that as best as possible
one just random bit of advice as well
and this is what
i kind of it's always stuck with me and
it's not relating to anything you've
just mentioned there
um but it's i i think i think throughout
my recruitment journey
what i did a lot was look over my
shoulder and look at other people in
other desks that were doing really well
and and always kind of think you know
what why is that oh they've got a really
good market oh they've been
they've fell on their feet they've just
gone into a really high-paying market
that does really well and
you know it's nothing it's you know it's
not them that's doing well it's the
marketplace and everything like that
and as i've grown and as i've seen every
market has the potential to be as good
as
you know the the one next to you it's
just about how you approach that market
and how you work that market
and it's very easy to try and compare
yourself to the person next year but
you're not the person next to you
so i think it's really important that
you know you're always just
really focused on on your what you're
trying to achieve
obviously take advice from your peers
you know look to them for aspiration
and advice as much as possible um but
yeah don't be disheartened when you see
someone under 30k deal when your average
aov is six seven grand because
you know that's good for the draw but
again it swings and roundabouts and and
uh you know
the the longer you're in the game and
the more consistent you are
and again time in market is a massive
massive factor in that you know
what from what you can accomplish in six
months to six you know to 18 months of
being in the same market
it can be very much worlds apart because
the longer you're doing it the longer
the more consistent you are the better
the results are going to be
no i love that i really appreciate you
being honest well let's
look let's um let's finish it there i
think that's a great way to end it
that's
a great piece of advice which i think
sometimes
people can learn the hard way and find
themselves comparing yeah i think we've
heard it a lot particularly from
top builders like really really focus on
yourself healthy competition great but
you're the only person that can improve
and if you really focus on that rather
than other people
then you're going to be in a good spot
but nathan really appreciate that thank
you so much for
pleasure got really practical with us
shared some really practical tips and
advice
and i'm uh yeah really excited to to see
how your business grows over
over the coming months and years so
thanks for coming on really appreciate
it thanks the opportunity